le corps ça a été pardon c'est
entièrement ma faute c'était pas blessé
il a quoi comme moyen
[Musique]
d'un bouquin sur battle Toad tu sais que
les jeux vidéos sont une des causes
majeures de divorce tu pourrais aussi me
commander un bouquin sur le sujet c'est
intéressant
mais souvent utilisé pour tenter de
masquer son acuculture
c'est pas possible
ça va Zoé
crois que je suis sa copine
soit il est mort hier soit je me suis
fait plaquer je me demande ce qu'il y a
de pire faut vraiment emménager Zac le
stress pourrait avoir des conséquences
sur son état tu fais quoi moi
passer pour l'autre Zoé vous vous
fréquentez depuis deux ou trois semaines
c'est bien ça
ouais
il est à l'Institut de technologie du
Massachusetts c'est pas vrai on a un mec
pour jouer c'est à cause de moi cet
accident et tu veux que je me mette à
draguer le cousin dans mes cames tu es
sérieuse on part tous ensemble demain
pour un week-end de ski tu pourrais
peut-être venir moi aussi l'être bande
de terre étroite
isthme comment tu as deviné vous êtes
forts tous les deux on y va on va se
faire une piste ça va déchirer
je suis en train de te faire découvrir
je trouve ça chouette
dans sa vie
tu crois que lui et toi vous êtes fait
l'un pour l'autre comme nous on est
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
je suis à vous la vérité
tu dois te battre pour le récupérer
faire preuve d'audace ma fille non mais
je rêve tu me fais un speech de comédie
romantique tu te trompes
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de
beau aujourd'hui tous les deux tu crois
qu'on peut leur dire nous dire quoi rien
d'interdit au moins de 13 ans
[Musique]